okay the m1 ultra in the mac studio
really beat out intel's 12 900k in
nvidia's rtx 3090
well we have some good news and some bad
news from some new benchmarks that were
just put out by real users apple made
some massive claims at their event
saying some unbelievable things
like them on ultra is 60 faster than the
28 core mac pro it absolutely smokes
intel's alder lake 12900k
and it even beats out the rtx 3090 while
using 200 watts less power or roughly a
third of that the only problem is that
apple is known to be very vague in those
charts they show off and with the m1
ultra it is even more vague this year
because many of these straight up just
say select industry standard benchmarks
and not what they are thankfully we now
have some of these benchmarks to see how
it compares to intel cpus and nvidia
graphics and with that we also have more
info on how the m1 ultra scales compared
to the m1 max as far as cooling and
wattage which we're gonna get into
talking about if it's actually worth
upgrading to the ultra and the 64 core
option and with that i have to let you
know that i bought three of these mac
studios going from a base model all the
way to a super high-end one so that we
can test them out and compare them and
show you guys the performance
differences if it's worth upgrading
certain components and options and how
much performance that will give you
depending on what you're doing so if you
guys want to see that make sure you guys
click that circle down below to
subscribe so you don't miss it and to
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers let's start out with apple's
first claim which is that the m1 ultra
in the mac studio is 60 faster than the
28 core mac pro which is a 7 000 cpu
upgrade over the already high six
thousand dollar base price they didn't
tell us what this test was but now we
have some more performance numbers to
see how it actually does in various
tests starting out with geekbench 5
somebody tested this m1 ultra and it got
a really high single core score of 1793
that's the highest i've seen for an m1
based chip
now the mac pro with that 28 core scores
1
152 so that is a difference of about 56
close to 60 so if that's what they're
kind of going off of that's not very
impressive because even like the macbook
air gets a similar single core score so
that's kind of weird now as far as
multi-core it got a score of 24 05 that
is very high beating out the 19
900 that the 28 core mac pro gives us
but that is still just a 20 difference
in performance not 60
now of course geekbench tests a lot of
different things as a short test not
maxing out the cpu for a long time which
is exactly what cinebench r23 does now
we don't have any leaked info for the m1
ultra but we do know is the performance
of the m1 max and with the cpu running
without any sorts of limitations that
scores nearly 12
600 points now with the m1 ultra it's
two of these chips
running at 60 watts which apple talked
about and of course the mac studio can
handle this no problem because the
graphics uses a lot more wattage so if
we go ahead and double the score we get
just over 25 000 which is a very
impressive score now this 28 core mac
pro it scores 24
244 meaning that yes even under extended
load the max studio with the m1 ultra
does beat it out but that is not 60
so that is just a little bit faster now
of course this is a 4 000 computer
compared to one that is roughly 15 000
if you end up upgrading the ram which
you have to get this performance so that
is really really good as far as bang for
the buck and of course we are comparing
to a year's old xeon processor not
intel's latest and greatest so what
happens if we take a look at intel's 12
900k that apple was showing off on stage
the alderley chip does beat out them on
ultra in single core performance which
is kind of weird to see because apple's
always so far ahead but this chip is
very fast but then if we take a look at
multi-core performance the m1 ultra
smokes it by about 40
in geekbench 5. now that is a very
impressive difference in performance
especially when we talk about how much
power this uses is about 60 watts
compared to about 160 at the base and up
to about 270 watts peak for this 12 900
k so that's a pretty nice result but if
we go ahead and take a look at 100 raw
cpu power in cinebench
this is where as long as you can give
enough cooling to this elder lake chip
which is like a triple liquid cooling
system alder lake actually beats the m1
ultra by about nine percent so what was
apple going off of with that wattage in
performance in favor of the m1 ultra
well we don't really know but what we do
know is for programs that are optimized
for apple silicon even though the raw
performance isn't as good they could be
way faster as we have shown you guys
even against windows for example
compiling mozilla firefox the m1 max was
almost as fast as a 12 900k compiling
that mozilla firefox it only took one
minute longer less than ten percent of
the difference and that was in a 14 inch
macbook pro so here we have double the
cores and way better cooling so for
certain workloads we are going to see
much much faster results now what about
graphics we have to talk about the rtx
3090 that apple kept referencing
what difference do we have there
well we do have a benchmark that came
out it's gfx bench and some performance
numbers gfx bench is very well optimized
for different platforms and the m1 max
and the 60-inch macbook pro beat out the
rtx 3080 in a razer laptop so it's very
very impressive so here we would expect
it to do well as well right well
unfortunately that's not really what we
see
if we take the 310 that it scored and we
double it you would have well 620
but the 16 inch macbook pro actually
throttled with the m1 max 32 core it
didn't scale the same as the other chips
did due to you know heat so properly
it'd be about 330 so we would expect
about 660
beating out the rtx 3090 which scores
about 505 frames per second so that'd be
the nice gain that they could have
showed but the results that we have is a
score of
484 frames per second here way lower so
what gives well we have a couple
scenarios the first scenario could be
that the m1 ultra the 64 core model is
thermally limited even in this mac
studio i talked about it previously and
talked about apple's graphs where it
seems like they're showing the m1 ultra
graphics only using 105 watts compared
to the m1 max showing the full 60 so it
could be limited just like them when max
was in this laptop and that would kind
of suck but since that video we also
found out that the m1 ultra is using a
much better cooling solution that weighs
nearly two pounds more
than with the m1 max it uses aluminum
and it is using copper so you would
think that if apple's going to this you
know amount of effort to be able to have
better cooling they wouldn't be limiting
this so the other option could be that
this result the m1 ultra gfx bench was
the bend 48 core model that cost a
thousand dollars less than the 64 core
if we take the 310 frames per second
that the m1 max gets and we divide it by
32 cores and then times it by 48 that
gives us
465 frames per second showing that we
actually get an even higher score here
at 484
and if we don't have any thermal
limitations and we go off of the proper
scaling the 330 number we get 495
whereas this score is right there for
the 48 core model if this is the case
that means that the 64 car model will be
reaching closer to 660 frames per second
absolutely smoking the rtx 30 90. of
course we're going to verify all of this
we love looking at the frequencies
wattage the thermals and if it's worth
spending the extra money how much more
performance you get so make sure you
guys have those notifications enabled
now the last test that we have to talk
about it's a more real world benchmark
that isn't really favored in terms of
mac silicon and that is puget bench's
excellent very extensive adobe premiere
pro benchmark now here we got some
performance numbers of the actual 64
core m1 ultra with 128 gigs of ram and
we're comparing it against the 12 900 k
with a 30 90 also 128 gigs of ram and
the performance numbers are pretty
promising the extended test which is
longer and tougher with m1 ultra scores
23
better than the alder lake and nvidia
combination that is a pretty good
difference in performance now the pure
gpu only performance here it's only
three percent higher in favor of the m1
ultra but when you look at the effects
rendering capability which also does use
a bit of cpu we see a much bigger
difference of 35
faster
for the m1 ultra that's pretty
impressive now as far as live playback
smoothness they are very very close and
then when you go to export which tests a
lot of different formats here the m1
ultra is 45 faster than the best intel
and nvidia combination that is a huge
performance difference you guys have to
keep in mind that premiere pro even
though it is optimized for apple silicon
it is not as well optimized as davinci
resolve and of course final cut so this
is something that's more in favor
towards the pc so that is where we're
seeing some more real world results that
are showing a lot more favorably for
this apple system but we're going to be
covering photo editing we're going to
talk about compiling code 3d rendering
with blender with the new version of
blender we're going to look at a lot of
real world tests so if you guys want to
see that make sure you guys click that
circle above to subscribe we can't wait
to get this check out one of those
videos over there this has been max and
i will see you in the next video
[Music]